foreign
hello everybody Welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is Joshua Fields Milburn
and I'm Ryan Nicodemus and together we
are the minimalists we're here with
malabama hi everybody TK Coleman what it
is we got the rest of our team here in
the studio as well and coming up today
on this free public minimal episode
we're talking to a listener and a
special guest we'll introduce you in a
moment but we're talking to a listener
about fear and self-doubt we also have
an outstanding lightning round segment a
live stream question a listener tip for
you and much much more but you can check
out the full three hour maximal edition
of episode 382 where we answer four
times the questions and we dive deep
into several simple living segments we
also argue about an advertisement that
private podcast episode is out right now
at patreon.com the minimalists your
support keeps our podcast and YouTube
Channel 100 advertisement free because
say it with me y'all advertisement suck
let's start with our callers if you have
a question or comment for our show give
us a call
406-219-7839 or email a voice memo to
podcast at the minimalists.com our first
question today is from Monique hi this
is Monique I'm in Northern Nevada I'm
holding on to too much of my fantasy
self and I know that is part of the
issue I also feel like I don't have
enough emotional support from my closest
loved one how can I overcome these
obstacles and fears when I'm trying to
live more minimal joining us in the
studio today to help us answer this
question and many other questions is the
podcaster and author Lewis Howes ladies
and gentlemen
now Lewis you've got a great show it's
called the school of greatness you also
have a brand new book out it is called
the greatness mindset in that book you
actually talk a lot about fear yes the
fear of judgment
and the fear of failure also strangely
the fear of success which I think is
applicable to Monique's question here as
well because Monique is dealing with a
lot of self-doubt and she's also dealing
with something she calls the fantasy
self there's nothing wrong with having
dreams obviously as my good friend TK
Coleman says dreams don't come true
decisions do but
quite often our dreams are someone
else's dreams and we feel a shame
because we're not living up to everyone
else's expectations and I was hoping
maybe you could shine a light on the
some of the fears that Monique is
experiencing well I think she was
talking about trying to connect with
certain people in her life is that what
she was saying like does she want more
intimate connection or what is she
wanting specifically from that question
I think there's a fear of there's the
self-doubt yep and there's a fantasy
self there's a self that she wants to
connect with or be there's a person that
she wants to be and as I said I don't
think there's anything wrong with with
wanting to be a person the question is
who wants you to be that person is this
something you want or is it an
expectation that Society has heaped on
to you yeah yeah well I think you become
what you envision yourself being but you
must believe you're worthy of that being
and so I don't know if she wants deeper
connection or intimacy or love or what
she's wanting from these relationships
but a lot of the fear in Intimacy in
relationships is I'm not deserving and
worthy of support I'm not serving and
worthy of love affection intimacy but
also in order to want that Intimacy in
your relationships you've got to be
willing to be vulnerable on risk
humiliation risk someone not receiving
you and that's one of the hardest things
the fear of judgment holds us back from
putting ourselves out there opening our
hearts and being more vulnerable
and it is scary for for essentially 30
years of my life I wasn't opening my
heart to intimate relationships because
I was afraid of other people's opinions
of me and that's when we live in more of
a powerless mindset when we are ruled by
the opinions of others I'm not saying
feedback critical coaching uh that is
important but when we are defined by the
opinions of others that really holds us
back from being intimate from being
vulnerable as you guys know the quality
of your life is directly related to the
quality of your relationships and the
quality of our relationships is directly
related to our ability to be vulnerable
with others and every time I open up
sometimes
uh with someone in my life that I care
about it's risky it's scary but usually
on the other side there's a deeper
connection and a deeper Bond and so
we've got to be willing to own and
reclaim the parts of us that we feel we
lost or we feel like we don't belong to
us anymore and when we own those things
again when we reconnect with the self
that is fearful scared or closed off
when we realign with ourselves whether
it be our younger self our wounded self
uh our fearful self and we create a new
relationship with self then we can open
up and connect with others hmm
you know she brought up a point too
about uh I think she said her closest
loved one who isn't super supportive so
I know in your book you talk about
garnering support from others um so yeah
what do you do when you have like a a
spouse who isn't super excited about
your you know in her case her minimalist
lifestyle yeah and uh yeah well I think
it's hard because you gotta first choose
properly I mean once you're in the
relationship if you've made the wrong
choice you've got to accept the person
you're with um
so that's why I made this mistake many
times I've had multiple relationships
over the last 15 years and they got to a
place of a year two years in where there
was so much friction but you care about
the person you love the person you
you've built this life with this person
and I lacked courage in the beginning
before exclusively committing
in all these relationships before about
asking what are your values what are
your vision what is your lifestyle and
lifestyle is one of the most important
things I think I I don't think opposites
really uh they might attract but they
don't work long term right you know what
I mean it's like okay I'm interested in
that way of being you're an extreme
person you go out there but then after
three to six months you're like I'm a
minimalist I don't want to go live this
life lifestyle is you have to align I'm
not saying it has to be 100 perfect but
there's got to be alignment if you don't
want clutter and everyone else just
wants to buy and fill up a space your
lifestyle doesn't align so a lot of it
is making sure you Choose Wisely and
then once you've chosen accepting the
person you're with my girlfriend
um
when I was getting into the relationship
with her there's a couple things that I
mean listen I don't know if this is
going to go down this path of
relationships but when I got into it I
really said I don't want to make the
same mistakes I've made in the past
which is connecting with people based on
sexual chemistry and attraction not on
spiritual alignment of values vision and
lifestyle and so when I was dating her I
was just asking her everything and she
was asking me everything and seeing are
we in alignment on these things there's
no right or wrong good or bad doesn't
mean like hey if you have a different
lifestyle cool but stepping into full
courage risking it not working out
allowed it allowed us to find Harmony
working out together and maybe I would
have to walk away if we did it online
and uh just because you love someone
doesn't mean it's going to be a life
story with them yeah I love what you
said about acceptance we have an acronym
t-a-r-a and it's really uh advice on how
to
get along with someone who maybe does
live a different lifestyle so T is uh to
tolerate that's like step number one
step number two is to accept and then it
goes into respect and then and then
appreciation but when you can get to
that acceptance piece it actually will
help you grow closer to someone's where
you can respect or uh get to a point
where you actually appreciate them yeah
when I got into uh before I committed to
my girlfriend I
I had to ask myself can I fully accept
who she is before I commit to her
because she's an actress she's a big
celebrity in Mexico she's done 40 movies
she has kissing scenes with guys in the
past like these things happen she's on
set with attractive guys or whatever it
is she's got a certain lifestyle and I
had to ask myself do I fully accept that
this is who she is right now she may be
this forever you know she may be this
way forever can I accept her
and I said okay I had to really check in
I'm like am I going to get jealous am I
going to get insecure or can I fully
accept her and I made the decision going
into the commitment to fully accept her
and I said listen
you know this hasn't happened yet at
least I said listen because I'm choosing
to fully accept you
there's no reason why I should ever get
upset at you I may be frustrated I may
be like disappointed I may be you know
we may disagree on things and argue in a
certain conscious way but I should never
be angry at you for who you are being
unless you are doing something out of
character that is different than what
you said is your values your vision and
your lifestyle again it doesn't mean I'm
not going to have challenging days with
you or like stressful moments
but we I want to create agreements that
we should never scream at each other it
should never be that hard or we scream
at each other so there's no yelling
there's no raising of voices because we
created alignment on our agreements and
so again it's because I've chosen to
accept her for who she is and not gotten
frustrated that she does things that
maybe I don't enjoy or like sometimes
I'm just like this is who she is I
accept her and I want to be fully
accepted I don't want you to be angry at
me for my lifestyle I don't want you to
change me you know you guys have the
whole thing what does it change the you
can't change the people around you but
can change the people around you or
choose to accept the people for who they
are and don't change them you know once
you accept them you don't have to change
people yeah and what I see in that is
the willingness to take a risk 100 I
think communication isn't just about
getting it right it's also about
embarking on that journey of discovering
what I need to know in order to make a
healthy relationship possible and
sometimes when we like have
vulnerabilities or needs we don't say
those things because we're afraid the
other person is going to respond in an
unkind way and then we end up creating
what one writer calls a self-fulfilling
idiocy that's when you assume that
another person's response to you is
going to be idiotic and insensitive and
so you proceed to react to them as if
they are already that and so you create
an outcome that is energetically
identical to them being idiotic and
insensitive and in a safe healthy
relationship you got to be comfortable
opening up your heart and saying this is
what I need and if you don't know if
that's possible for you it's worth
finding out even if that process is
uncomfortable and so one thing I would
say Monique is
if you want to connect with your partner
and you need more support you gotta
express it if for no other reason that
you need to know where you stand in your
relationship when it comes to getting
the support and what I would do is
instead of just saying I need your
support I would write down a few
specific manifestations of what support
looks like for me and I would articulate
that hey it's my goal to get to bed by
nine o'clock every night would you mind
helping you know nudge me in that
direction hey it's my goal to sign up
for this painting class by the end of
the month would you mind checking in on
me to just hold me accountable to that
what does support look like don't assume
that they know what that means for you
spell it out ask them in a form of a
request and see where that takes you
yeah for me it's all about agreements
you know early in the uh
the relationship with Martha my
girlfriend
there was a couple nights where she like
had some you know some concerns in her
mind and she would bring them up at like
11 and 12 o'clock at night after like my
head's already down I'm like half asleep
and she starts talking I don't know if
the lady's listening can uh connect with
that will you ever bring up something on
your mind to your partner uh late at
night and after a few nights like one
night we were just up for like hours
talking about something again we weren't
screaming but we were just like kind of
going through some stuff and I was like
this doesn't work for me like we need to
create a new agreement
where I because I want to best serve you
with my energy I want to be present with
you and are you not setting me up for
Success when we have a conversation
after 11 o'clock or midnight when I'm
half asleep
and so let's create an agreement where
we don't have these challenging
conversations once we're in bed or
before you know after 10 o'clock at
night like there is no challenging
conversations set us up for Success so
we can do it in a more conscious loving
way
and find more resolution around that so
it's just creating agreements and asking
for those things with your partner yeah
wow so what you did is you basically
asked for support from your partner and
you're saying Hey I want to be the best
version of myself around you so here's
the support I need to be the best
version of myself what a great way to
like try to yeah I want one of those
agreements what's thinking about like I
want you to have everything you need
but in order to do that you can't bring
this up at midnight you know when I'm
half asleep I can't otherwise I have to
turn the lights back on and like sit up
and be present and then we go to 130 and
then we both lose sleep so like let's
just talk about it tomorrow or talk
about before 10. you know wait you do it
before bed you know what I mean
um and I think that's it's created a lot
more Harmony yeah again my goal is to
find more peace and Harmony in my life
so that I can draw back the energy to me
and use it towards being better every
single day use it towards my mission use
it towards being present with my friends
use it towards my workouts it's just
it's not about good and bad right and
wrong it's not a judgment it's about
what is more effective yeah what is more
useful in your life I love what you're
both talking about here because I'm
hearing the boundaries piece of it and
that helps eliminate fears and also the
specificity you're talking about support
support can be really nebulous as TK
highlighted I need you to support me
more Ryan what does that mean well I
don't know but do it I just don't feel
supported right and that feeling is not
wrong right but our desire to be
supported then creates a thought that
creates the fear and so I want to Circle
back to the to the fear component of
this because fear tends to be a
byproduct of invented consequences we
think about all of these things yose the
Buddha who said that a wise man has no
fear and is thus ultimately free and so
the no fear thing we often think of as
like well of course fear is just natural
another great Philosophy for 50 Cent
said that
every philosopher good from Alabama
likes the uh the juxtaposition of black
Buddha and 50 Cent but 50 says that fear
is a choice
danger is real yep and so quite often
what happens we mistake
the thing we're worried about I'm
worried that my partner won't support me
I'm worried that I can't get rid of my
fantasy self I'm worried that I'm going
to be worried tomorrow yes I'm worried
I'm worried I'm worried and we turn it
into a monster there's no real danger
there here's the irony though when there
is real real clear and present danger if
this room is set on fire right now you
actually don't have that kind of fear
you don't worry about the future you
take action right now I don't have to go
read the fire safety manual to figure
out what's the three steps to put out
the fire or what are the four things I
should do to exit the room I simply act
when there is danger and so Louis I want
to talk to you about fear because one of
the things you talk about in the book is
the fear of success maybe you can expand
on that a bit well there's three main
fears the fear of failure success and
judgment and there's a route to each one
of these fears but when I go around and
talk to people and I'll ask people in
the room like raise your hand if you've
ever been afraid of failure and it's
what causes you to not take action on
writing the book you've wanted to write
for 10 years or launching the show or
getting out of the relationship or
whatever it is uh and you know 78 of the
room will raise their hand as a fear of
failure and I understand that you know
that's a lot of people's fears when I
ask people how many here are afraid of
success almost the exact amount raise
their hand as afraid of success and I'm
like
you're here because you want to learn
how to be more successful but you're
afraid of it so why would success come
to you if you're afraid of it if you're
if you're in resistance to receiving it
why would it come to you you're probably
going to self-sabotage or abandon self
in order to resist receiving it and I
never understood it because as an
athlete
you play sports right I don't know if
these guys did but you play sports these
guys can't hang with me
you're a Hooper or what what'd you play
sport basketball man you know what I'm
saying
when we uh you know we're playing
basketball growing up you know if you
had a good coach
he uh he would encourage you to fail to
try that's right and you're going to
miss the shot Jordan missed what half of
his shots at least and he's one of the
greatest of all time if not the greatest
of all teams
she got the brawn in the mix I don't
know he's uh you don't even realize what
you just brought up again
I think he's I think he's the goat but I
mean hey we're gonna have to table that
TK is gonna be very upset I mean look at
score but um you know
these guys in the top of their game
mishap their shots you know the best
baseball players Miss there's they lose
70 of the time they don't succeed right
so they're failing more than they're
succeeding and they're the greatest of
all time
uh at only succeedings 30 of the time so
in sports you know we can relate to this
growing up we knew that failure was the
path to success it's just the practice
you got to put in to get feedback
information on how to adjust our shot
you know and how to dunk a little bit
better could you dunk nah man
you didn't have the Hops but it was just
whatever you needed to do to learn it
was never a bad thing it was like you're
trying as long as the attitude the
energy and the effort is there you're
gonna get better right so so failure
wasn't something I was afraid of because
I knew it was a part of the path to
success it was just about getting the
right feedback watching the game film
seeing how I can improve and success is
what I always wanted but I wanted it
from a wound
I wanted it to prove people wrong I
wanted it to to for the three guys that
laughed at me in you know the sports
team early on when I wasn't good when I
was picked last uh you know for all the
whatever girls that rejected me I wanted
to prove the world wrong yeah and so I
was driven to succeed to fulfill a
desire of being liked being respected
being more powerful or whatever it was
so when we're driven to overcome
something that is a fear of ours by some
other fear typically when we receive the
results it still doesn't feel good
enough so I would succeed in sports I
succeeded in business and it wasn't
until I hit 30 years old when I was like
why is all these goals that I'm
accomplishing I can work hard I can
accomplish goals but I'm not feeling
joyful happy fulfilled enough it's
because I was doing it from a wound the
fear of judgment
but it wasn't I wasn't afraid to act out
of the fear of success
the fear of judgment was my kryptonite
and it was the thing that I've had to
learn over and over again uh
that this will continue to hold me back
in every area of Life unless I learn to
embrace it accept myself in it and
continually overcome it and it was the
opinions of other people right I was
more afraid so I could act
I could take action
I could succeed but then when people
would leave nasty reviews I couldn't
deal with it I would have to defend
myself at all costs I would have to
reply to people and people please I
would have to give in and do all these
things so that people would like me
and at the center the root of all these
fears of what holds us back from each
one of them is I am not enough is the
feeling that I'm not enough I'm not
worthy enough not deserving not lovable
enough not smart enough not talented
enough uh you know and not intelligent
enough all these different things
and underneath that is
a story
is a wound somewhere that we must heal
and create new meaning around memories a
memory or multiple memories that back
this belief
and when we can create new meaning as
Viktor Frankel talks about
and Empower ourselves in the new meaning
that supports Us in overcoming these
fears that's when we can have a more
fulfilling
flowing life yeah and I think that's
what it's about it's just about being
aware which fear is causing me to doubt
myself the most is it supporting me is
it useful to have this fear is it a
danger fear like a physical danger most
of the time it's not be prepared for
physical Danger
but the psychological and emotional
dangers of Life Judgment of other people
or whatever it might be or be
that is not serving you to stepping into
who you're capable of being and that's
when we need to realize like okay
there's some healing that can be done as
uh Dr John Maloney is that his last name
yeah you guys know him well deloney
deloney sorry Malone I'm thinking you
know Alabama am I freaking all these you
know
um I was just with him and you know his
book owner in your past is all about we
cannot have a great present our future
unless we take full acceptance and
ownership of our past that means there's
a lot of stuff that we don't want to
face and address I don't care if you've
had some big traumas or little traumas
we've got to face all of it yeah and
we've got to create meaning from all
these different moments of our past and
have full claiming and ownership of it
when we do that we can step into the
things we want to create with more power
and presence yeah Ryan what time is it
you know what time it is it's time for
the lightning round where we answer your
questions from Tick Tock because we are
cool and hip and have a tick tock
we're at the minimalist on Tick Tock
also Instagram Facebook and Twitter you
can follow us there with your social
media questions now during the lightning
round this is where we each have 60
seconds to answer your question with a
short shareable less than 140 character
response we put the text to these
minimal maxims in the show notes so you
can copy and share our pithy answers on
social media if you'd like you can find
those show notes by the way over at the
minimalists.com podcasts
Alabama who's our question from today
this one comes from Aditya she says
needing a thing creates worry but
doesn't that conflict with having
ambition all right before we put any
time on the clock here let me be clear
about what this is a response to so we
put up a video on Tick Tock and it was
this is only part of it part of it also
said that wanting a thing creates Wonder
needing the thing creates worry and it
was making that distinction something
that Lewis was talking about with us
today in our expanded conversation on
the private podcast when you get to do
something you want to do something you
feel that sense of awe that sense of
wonder
when it's like oh I have to do this well
that becomes a a type of prison and you
start to worry when you've imprisoned
yourself so that was the fundamental
essence of the video that this person is
questioning but then they brought in a
third component and that's that
component of ambition so Professor Sean
let's put 60 seconds on the clock for my
good friend Ryan you let me go first all
right let's do it um but the answer is
this to need a thing is to pretend you
are incomplete without it so to need
something there's nothing wrong with
needing something we would never tell
people that hey you shouldn't need
anything it's more about when you need
something be very clear on why you need
that thing I need water I need food I
need shelter I need good friends in my
life like that's okay but once we start
to need something we start to feel
incomplete oh he did that in half the
time he just dribbled right between the
legs dunked it right over TK Coleman
didn't even throw a pass I was I was
DK right now because he has 60 seconds
to give you something pithy
ambition does not require attachment
ambition is when you say it is in accord
with my highest excitement to pursue the
following path attachment is when you
say and if I fail I'm gonna hate myself
and hate everybody else for not getting
what I wanted ambition is when you say
this is the adventure that makes me come
alive attachment is when you say and if
I don't win
then I'm not gonna be well attachment is
rooted in self-doubt it's rooted in fear
and mistrust ambition in its unhealthy
mode of expression can be rooted in
those things but it doesn't have to be
you don't have to pursue a life you love
from a place of hating where you are now
ambition when healthfully expressed can
simply be a playful and joyful
expression of your enthusiasm for
possibility you can go after something
not because you hate yourself and you
hate your life but simply because you
enjoy the creative process and all of
the beauty that it brings I love it man
I feel like we should have a little
snapping sound effect that uh mahalik
should put in I love about how Lewis
house is doing that
[Music]
60 seconds Ryan I went back to the Vault
for this one 2011 our first book
minimalism live a meaningful life
there's a line in that book and it is
this it is not ambition that sets A Man
Apart
it is the distance he is prepared to go
now obviously that's gender neutral
woman apart person apart it's not
ambition in fact ambition ends up being
a byproduct of the distance you are
prepared to go if you find something
truly compelling the way that Lewis
Howes found handball compelling or salsa
dancing compelling these things that he
talked about on the private podcast he
found them so compelling he didn't need
ambition to do those things he found
them compelling enough to actually
immerse himself in it he was prepared to
go the distance and from an outside
Observer he may look ambitious but what
he really was was devoted to that
particular task activity and that is
what took him the distance yeah
we'll check in with the patreon live
stream here in a moment but first real
quick for right here right now here's
one thing that's going on in the life of
the minimalist you know on the private
podcast each week we do a minimalist
home tour we go into the homes of Ryan
and TK and and my home we're also going
to be opening up to our patrons and we
can go into some of their homes as well
if you want a sample of that we have it
up on YouTube right now you can find it
it's called The minimalist living room
tour you can just go to minimalists.com
living room it will take you straight
there if you want to take a a look
inside one of our homes do a living room
tour and we also talk about some of the
things that we own there as well so if
you want a minimalist home tour updated
one you can find it on our YouTube
channel or just at the minimalists.com
living room dude my favorite home tour
that we've done is when me and Mariah
did our apartment have you seen that TK
I think I was here for that no no I mean
it was a couple years ago but I mean it
was just like floating around the
internet but long story short Mariah and
I were moving so our apartment was empty
and I got this or maybe it was Jordan's
great idea but we had this idea like oh
we're gonna like film as if minimalists
don't own anything and it was complete
satire it was hilarious though like it
was one of my favorite things and he
truly owned nothing he was using his
yoga mat as like a bath towel and uh
they were pretending they were sitting
on furniture miming playing the piano is
that the one where your grandmother was
like I think you ought to let people
know that's not real oh God love grams
yeah she was like I saw your video about
you owning nothing that's just not true
you own things and I'm like uh
you're right uh comedy we got any
comments from the live stream we sure do
we have a comment here from Dr Ben he
said I just tuned in to hear the part
about dancing and looking at others
instead of imagining others judging you
great I enjoy this a lot yeah Lewis was
so great you can tune into the full
private podcast see our full
conversation with him you can also check
out his book it's called the greatness
mindset let's tune in to one question
from the patreon live stream here's a
question from Claudio I often find
myself trying to take over a struggling
business than later being afraid of
having to close it down it's like I'm
always expecting to have the rug pulled
out from under me how can I unpack this
fear
so I have that fear of the rug always
being pulled out from underneath me and
for me it routes back to Childhood it's
like no matter what like before the age
of 18 before I was able to move out and
like make my own decisions something
great would be happening and then
something bad would a company accompany
it so for me it Roots back to this
childhood trauma we're like I'm at my uh
Grandma's it's Christmas we're having a
good time and then you know I get a call
from my stepdad hey your mom's in jail
she got a DUI it's like oh like and this
is just one of many examples and that
was like the um that was the you know
the the PG example that I could give
because there's so many others that I
don't want to really get into but for me
what I've realized is a couple things
um sometimes there is no rug like the
rug is imaginary but let's say there is
something that could be swept out from
underneath of you
I have to tell myself like hey Ryan your
parents aren't in control anymore like
you are in control you get to make the
decisions and if something happens
that's okay but no one is going to take
this rug out from underneath of you
except yourself
I think the whole world is an Etch A
Sketch and as soon as I realized that I
felt the same way as he did as Ryan did
the rug can always be swept out from
under me and it's going to be but then
when you realize it's going to be no
matter what on a long enough timeline
that Etch A Sketch is going to get
shooken and as soon as you shake that
extra sketch what happens it's a clean
start it's fresh all over again and so
whenever I look at the world I recognize
that everything that we've done every
book that we've written every podcast
that we've done every tour that we've
done I mean think about even the tours
that we've done Ryan most of the
original tourist house we Never filmed
any of that yeah it's all gone yeah and
that's okay it's all going to be gone on
a long enough timeline and at first
that's upsetting it's depressing but
when you step back and you look at it
it's incredibly freeing because you know
that it is in ever so why worry about
the thing that's inevitable yeah yeah
that's absolutely right you know
sometimes our fear is a sign that there
are areas where we need to actually take
the reins and sometimes our fear is a
sign that there are areas where we need
to let go of the need to have control or
rather that the illusion that we could
have control in the first place and I
would take a look at the situations I'm
in when I take over these struggling
companies and I would ask myself all
right what are the legitimately grounded
fears where there are things I need to
take control of there are things I need
to prepare for and plan for and what are
those things that fall into the category
of me being afraid that a comet might
strike the Earth in 10 seconds and take
us all away the things I can't do
anything about and let go of the things
in that second category and learn from
your fear
as they pertain to the things in that
first category and that allows you to
move forward constructively but when you
parcel them out you can escape that
sense of being Ambiguously confused
isn't it funny how that fear that we the
story that we tell ourselves of things
that could happen like in a in a way
it's it's us giving ourselves certainty
it's like this um I don't know this
Primal
um this primal thing that we've always
had as humans like to to be on the
lookout for predators to be on the
lookout for uh you know Dangerous Waters
whatever it is but looks like it
transfers over to
oh no what if I don't you know make x
amount of dollars next month yeah and
the thing about fear is it never
actually serves you if you see that
clear and present danger that we talked
about earlier
the fear goes away and action appears
and so any fear that we have yes it
might be a signpost it might tell us to
be more prepared for the thing but even
if you're Paralyzed by fear because
you're in the woods and a bear is coming
after you that fear is not serving you
there either right if you can be
prepared for the danger then perhaps you
can get away from the danger but if
you're Paralyzed by fear it's actually
going to do the opposite of what you're
hoping that the fear will do yeah it
won't prevent the harm it will create a
bunch of harm along the way until the
inevitable does happen which by the way
the inevitable always does happen I want
to check back in with the patreon live
stream here in a little bit but first
from Alabama what do you got for us
here's a minimalist Insight from one of
our listeners
hi my name is Clara dahil I'm from
Amherst Massachusetts
so I really enjoy your podcast
um I am in the military I'm a member of
the Coast Guard and I'm really liking
seeing the connection between middle and
Muslim and being the military you know
we have the same uniform every day
really just a basic amount of stuff and
just having that freedom of everything
you need just keeping in what we call
our seabed which is that green military
life backpack thank you and I really
enjoy your podcast
all right that's our minimal episode for
today we'll see you on patreon for the
full three hour maximal edition of
episode 382 which includes answers to a
bunch more questions with our good
friend Lewis Howes questions like how do
we break free from procrastination and
behaviors that don't move us toward our
goals how can I move past fear and
self-judgment to reach my fullest
potential plus a million more questions
we also this week have a private
minimalist home tour you get to see my
Spartan workspace at home and it is
aggressively minimal we also have a new
obsolete object segment we talk about
why reusable water bottles
totally obsolete well maybe not totally
we can even argue about that a bit we
have an outstanding added value segment
for you one of my new favorite songs of
the Year and much much much more of less
and if you want to hear all that check
out the minimalist private podcast at
patreon.com the minimalist or click the
link in the description to subscribe and
get your personal links so that our
weekly maximal episodes play in your
favorite podcast app you'll also gain
access to all of our archives all the
way back to episode zero zero one and if
you're still on the fence here's a
testimonial from one of our lovely
patreon supporters Scott says I really
appreciate the discussions that happen
on the private podcast especially the
episodes where you three are not in
alignment and are working through your
disagreements on air it's a great
demonstration of how to have a
meaningful conversation without judgment
or anger oh that's awesome man yeah it's
it's crazy because like I was talking to
someone the other day and I was saying
how we lack
um examples in the media of how to have
a disagreement without jumping down each
other's you know or yeah jumping on each
other's throats so I'm so glad you said
that because I think we do a good job of
that too and I wish there was more
examples of that out in the world but um
but hey we're doing it yeah and I think
the reason we see that is because a lot
of the disagreements are less about
being curious towards other people's
positions and the reasons behind them
and they're really battles for the moral
High Ground I have the position that
good people have and I'm going to begin
this conversation with you by assuming
that your failure to believe my position
means you're morally inferior to me now
let's talk yes and by the way as soon as
you get up on this pedestal with me and
agree with everything I say then you too
will be good and what a terrible way to
approach to initiate a conversation yeah
and I think the first thing we try to do
is step down from those pedestals even
when we had an argument like we did
today on the private podcast about the
advertisements it was much more
inquisitive it wasn't an actual argument
and it was about getting clarity about
the understanding of the other person
and as soon as we do that there's no
pedestal needed
and not only that man
but the problem with the moral High
Ground is that all of the people that
are suffering and who need help they're
on the ground and all the work that's
happening to make the world better is
work that's happening on the ground
but the moral High Ground is appealing
precisely because of that
because it allows us the appearance of
virtue while also escaping the messiness
and the humility
that's experienced on the ground because
you know what the hardest part about
helping people is unlike when we're on
podcasts unlike when we're lecturing
from our podiums and our pulpits when
you're helping people you gotta let them
teach you you don't present yourself to
them as some savior or as some good
person you present yourself to them as a
humble servant hey struggling person you
educate me amen big thanks to Our Guest
today Lewis Howes his new book is called
the greatness mindset I'm holding enough
if you're watching the video version
here you can also check out his show
it's called the school of greatness
we'll put links to both of those in the
show notes and if you leave here today
with just one message
let it be this
love people
and use things
because the opposite never works thanks
for listening y'all we'll see you next
time peace
every little thing you think that you
need
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed or I bet that you'll
be fine without it thank you foreign
every little